like can you can you say that Jesus
taught his disciples that that he was
God yes I can and so this is where the
problem comes my friend is because
you're right there are a bunch of places
in the Quran while at the same time that
it says it confirms the Torah and the
gospel and that these books are true and
they're Revelations of God it also goes
directly against things that we see in
the Bible like Jesus being God or being
the Son of God or him being crucified
the problem then is not with the Bible
the problem is with the Quran because
it's saying that these very book these
this book that it's contradicting it's
saying that it's true it's saying that
we should follow the Torah and the
gospel we should believe in it and judge
by it it God sent it as the law that he
prescribed on us and if we don't observe
it we're wrongdoers and evildoers your
your Scholars your modern day Scholars
by the way not your early Islamic
scholars like tabar and Kur because they
agree that there were differences in the
qurans that existed then but in the 20th
and 21st century your Scholars have been
repeating repeating the Trope there's
only one Quran every Quran wherever you
go to in in the entire world is exactly
the same dot for DOT letter for letter
that has been the message for the past
Century from your Quran Scholars from
your Islamic scholars they've been lying
there there has not been you can't
produce you can't show me like different
Gans like right now you can't really
show me that because every single
scholar has told what have we been
talking about what what have we been
talking about this whole you know okay
listen if you take King of the day of
judgment and you take owner of the day
of judgment and you call these two what
if you take you were surprised Muhammad
versus Allah saying I was surprised
Muhammad what about that okay I get what
point you're getting at I find it
interesting that in order to dismantle
try to dismantle my ground you have to
dig like meters me deep in order to do
that whereas I don't have to do much to
dismantle you think I'm digging
meters minutes I'm quoting this stuff
off the top of my head I don't even have
to go into my research to go ahead and
disprove you hold off the top of my head
wait please
please I feel like you're you're I don't
know what you if you know what's going
on here goad I don't have to dig deep
for this I I just know this all it takes
and matter of fact no one listening
needs to dig deep for this all you have
to do is read bro that's all you got to
do is read you have to do what you have
to do do what you have to do to try to I
guess disparage the gospel in my
position is you have to make up stuff
and make up a standard that you yourself
as a Muslim can't even uphold to okay so
are you saying is your argument now okay
the Quran is not reliably transmitted
that means it's okay that my Bible is
not reliably transmitted absolutely not
absolutely not this is what I'm saying
here it is again here's the main point
because I don't want you to miss it
here's the main point you put a standard
on the Bible on the gospel saying one
the authors are Anonymous we don't know
who they are yet you that's that's Point
number one that you brought up yes which
is very when it comes to the gospel the
in that you believe in you don't know
who wrote it these authors are Anonymous
to you so this is a reason why you
should reject this injil that the Quran
talks about because it's authors are
Anonymous you see all I'm doing is the
standard that you apply to me I'm also
applying to you showing you that you if
you're going to be consistent and honest
the reasons why you reject my gospel
which I don't totally agree with but I'm
just granting you your reasons okay that
you that you reject my gospel are the
reasons you should reject the Quran and
the inil okay Anonymous authors
two you said that the gospel was written
by men who are not prophets and didn't
have the authority or the direct
approval face Toof face with Jesus with
what they wrote do do we know anything
about
them history about them just focus on
the main point here okay so if we should
reject the gospel or the gospel has
problems because it it was written by
men who claimed it was from God um who
didn't get a direct uh overview of what
they wrote from Jesus himself and that's
why we should reject it then you should
reject the Quran because your Quran is
written by men who are not prophets
wrote it with their own hands didn't
have the authority of the Prophet nor
did they have the overview of Muhammad
to solidify what they wrote down okay so
you should reject the Quran and you
should reject the inil that your Quran
talks about okay so now let's talk about
the difference the difference is we know
the names we know the background we know
the history of every single person that
has laid hand on the Quran we know them
by we know them it's all written down we
know their character we know where they
lived we knew how they lived we knew if
they were Liars or not we know all this
all this is documented we all all of
them had the entire Quran memorized all
of them had the whole thing memorized
now let's go back to Matthew Mark Luke
and John people who are Anonymous we
don't know nearly how anous we have
their Nam dude Matthew Matthew was a tax
collector living in living in Jerusalem
Jesus pulled him out okay uh Mark full
name John Mark also companion of Peter
and Paul Luke a physician a doctor also
companion of briek by the way okay John
son of zebede brother of James the
direct disciple and Apostle of Jesus
okay you're you're giv memor and and
they memorize the words of Jesus and
they had a direct experience with God
being being endowed and filled with
God's very own Spirit to where they were
able to do Miracles they were Inspire
wait who who was inspired to do Miracles
Matthew or who joh did Miracles Peter
all of them yes they did Miracles they
did Miracles yes yeah so so now here's
my question so now that I was able to
give you information on these people
with their names who they were even some
of their family members you still don't
have an excuse here you gave their
titles dude you barely gave me anything
you just said this guy's a doctor he's
the brother of this guy you you're you
know oh so looks like looks like we know
something about them huh okay yeah you
know the bare minimum dude you know the
bare minimum okay nice looks like we
know enough about
them looks like we know enough about
them especially with them being
Companions of Jesus memorizing what
Jesus said and even even Jesus says to
them he's he says this he says the holy
spirit will come to you and bring to
your remembrance all that I have taught
you so Jesus says that when he goes away
they're going to remember everything he
said and and convey it Jesus Jesus Jesus
but who who in whose gospel in Jesus's
gospel so joh wrot this down Jesus said
it though John's gospel not Jesus's
gospel it's Jesus's gospel also and let
me say wa wait wait stop stop right
there stop right there it's Jesus's
gospel that John Gospel according to
John so so here's my question who wrote
the inel because you still haven't
answered that who if you ask me who
wrote the Bible there is no no no I
didn't ask who wrote the Bible who wrote
theil dude God revealed the inil whoever
wrote it down afterwards it's we don't
know them we don't know so let me get
this straight so your inal has Anonymous
authors my inil we don't have any inil
with us there's no present day in it's
getting worse so the inil is gone it's
lost we don't have it with on the
initial thing your inil that you believe
in that your Quran talks about has
Anonymous authors you don't know them we
don't know them no do you but do you
believe in this Ino I believe it because
the Quran says it oh man beautiful so
you believe in this Ino although this
Gospel of Jesus although its authors
were Anonymous here's my here's my
second question its authors were not
Anonymous the author was God God is the
one who revealed the in wa wait so so
Allah himself wrote down the the gospel
wrote it down dude I get what you're
getting at but this is
this is such a lousy point in my opinion
man it's it's lousy when you're when
you're on the skillet getting cooked it
is it doesn't it it's not a good feeling
I imagine this is what the Quran says I
imagine getting cooked on the grill is
not a good feeling I imagine you are
okay listen the Quran says we have
revealed the Torah and we have revealed
the gospel and we have revealed this
Quran as a dude come on really man
that's just I don't get it are you just
trying to be annoying or something okay
bro I'm sure you're having fun right now
now do you you believe Jesus Is God or
something do you believe God is a man
ah there it is what no I'm serious I
mean you're laughing right now you're
doing this whole thing but look at this
y'all no what you were preaching some
come look at this somebody come look at
this man what you are preaching right
now is something that Jesus with along
with every other Prophet did not preach
look at this somebody come look at this
I'm so
serious so now you trying to is Jesus
God your way out of this huh no no no no
I just said that because I think it's
funny like you're laughing as if you did
something and I just think you you are
incredibly misguided I just
think so you trying to is Jesus gu your
way out of this let me ask you this do
you do you feel like we could we can
skip the let me let me finish what I was
saying we can move on we can move on but
I want to finish this one point to move
on to no no no no no let me say because
I wanted to say this verse okay say what
verse we have revealed this Torah we
revealed the gospel and we have revealed
this Quran as a decisive authority over
care who wrote it who wrote the Gospel
wait wait wait okay dude it doesn't
matter who wrote it the point of of this
is the Quran the Quran is saying that we
have that the Quran that God has
revealed these uh messages before and
the Quran is a way is a is a decisive
authority over them your Quran one never
says that number two say that it does
say that here's my question okay here's
my question here's my question and
listen one who submits I I will say
definitely I do like you this is why
you've been here this long I like you
you're I'm enjoying having this
conversation with you man too me too so
this is my question to you man when you
don't know who the authors are of the
Gospel um Let me let me correct it when
you don't know who the writers the
scribes are of the
Gospel how do you know that Matthew Mark
Luke and John did not write it when you
don't know who did um even if they did
write it I don't see um how that that
really matters all right so let's pause
here the reason why this matters one who
submits is because your initial
objection to what I have is Jesus was
not walking around preaching Matthew
Mark Luke and John right but we we
settled on that Jesus wasn't walking
around with anything just an oral
message and that later on his oral
message this gospel was written down
eventually now I'm saying you're you're
disagreeing that I have the Gospel of
Jesus because of who we attribute the
writings to Matthew Mark Luke and John
this is why it matters dude if you're
saying that I don't have the Gospel of
Jesus because Matthew Mark Luke and John
are the writings of the Gospel of Jesus
that we appeal to yeah that's not it
then who wrote it matters that's why
yeah when I ask you how do you know that
Matthew Mark Luke and John didn't write
the inel when you don't know who did I
get what you're saying I get what you're
saying my whole thing is when it comes
to like all these uh these when it comes
to these specific details it's not
something that we like like as I said we
see the Quran as a decisive authority
over what is true and what is not true
and and there is a verse there is a
verse on it where it literally does say
that God has revealed previous
scriptures and then there are other
verses that talk about how people
differed upon those scriptures and XYZ
and then in that same verse that says
that we have revealed the Tor and the
gospel it says we have revealed the
Quran as a decisive authority over them
so judge between them and what has God
has revealed it's in thean I can pull it
up for you well the verse that you're
talking about is 548 it doesn't say it's
a decisive authority over them it says
it's a guardian a mahim over them a
guardian not a decisive judge over them
or authority over them this is another
thing that people are lying about
getting this cons screwed which verse
chapter 5 verse 48 5 verse 48 the word
is mahim which means Guardian not
decisive authority over some something
let's see this is what it says it says
um we've revealed to you oh Prophet this
book with the truth as a confirmation of
previous scriptures and a supreme
authority on them did you hear what I
just said I I heard what you said but
I'm I'm showing you uh I'm going I'm on
quran.com
particular you're using a particular
translation that translates the word MIM
incorrectly as saying now you're in
quran.com which is good actually you're
on quran.com on quran.com can you hover
over the word mahim or where it's
supposed to say supreme authority hover
over that word in the Arabic and see
what what pops up what does it say
okay okay I see yes and a guardian over
it yes so you see how they mistranslated
that word putting their own thought into
it trying to make it say something that
it's not saying it's decis it's not that
it's not that it's the word it in when
Arabic words they can they entail things
you know what I mean it's not as simple
as just the word on the surface so this
word in this Arabic language it entails
that you know it doesn't no it doesn't
it does not see matter of fact
especially when you read the context my
brother the context doesn't give you
that because if you continue reading
verse 48 how do you interpret so like
just continue reading verse 48 you'll
see that it's not saying that the Quran
is a decisive authority over the
previous scriptures it's not saying that
it's a guardian of the scriptures right
it it's a it it validates its truth
right but it's not a authority to say
what part of the scriptures right or
wrong it's the other way around and if
you continue reading verse 48 it
eventually says that to each of you to
each group it's talking about Jews
Christians and the Muslims because if
you go to verse 43 it's talking about
Jews verse 46 and 47 it's talking about
Christians and then verse and I like
this verse I like this verse you're I do
too I I like the whole context 43 to 48
I I like the whole context yeah it's
very good so it's talking about these
three groups that Allah gave Revelation
to Jews Christians and Muslims 48 it's
it's basically wrapping up the point yes
to each of you we have prescribed to you
your own law yes right so each of you
has an authoritative Revelation from God
that you are all supposed to live by yes
okay and it literally says continues if
we wanted to we would have made you one
nation right yes but you know basically
test what you do good exactly make sure
that you compete in doing good follow
your own law that we've given you yes so
the quran's not an authority over the
Torah or the gospel the Quran the Quran
what the Quran does is it tells the
Muslims what's authoritative for them to
follow yes I see what you're saying I
see what you're saying but also um it's
it's not that that shouldn't be
interpreted as oh like the Quran is
saying uh you know that my religion is
valid in XYZ because there are other
verses in the Quran that completely
dismantle the idea of the Trinity or the
idea of Jesus being God so to so when
you look at context you have to see it
as as what it's talking about is the
message at its core the message that was
given to Moses at its core the message
that was given to Jesus at its core like
can you can you say that Jesus taught
his disciples that that he was God yes I
can and so this is where the problem
comes my friend is because you're right
there are a bunch of places in the Quran
while at the same time that it says it
confirms the Torah and a gospel and that
these books are true and their
Revelations of God
um it also goes directly against things
that we see in the Bible
like Jesus being God or being the Son of
God or him being
crucified sorry go ahead sorry it
directly goes against these things right
but here's the problem the problem then
is not with the Bible the problem is
with the Quran because it's saying that
these very book these this book that
it's contradicting it's saying that it's
true it's saying that we should follow
the Torah and the gospel we should
believe in it and judge by it it God
sent it as the law that he prescribed on
us and if we don't observe it we're
wrongdoers and evildoers so it puts our
book on a pedestal saying that it's true
and if we don't follow it we're
wrongdoers and going to hell but at the
same time it contradicts the book that
it's a you know what what it affirms
what it affirms is like I said the core
message that came to each prophet and
their teaching that's what it affirms
it's a it's affirming that Jesus was a
true uh a true Prophet sent by God and
that his message was true it's affirming
that because think about it like this
the Arabs at that time the Arabs at that
time before Islam came to them they had
two options either they they can accept
what the Jews say that Jesus was a false
Messiah and he was a a traitor XYZ or
they can accept what the Christian says
that Jesus is God and that we should
worship Him and XYZ there and the Quran
came as a way to say that Jesus's
message was the true message of God and
that people have differed uh in that in
that message that's also in the Quran so
it's not that it just says oh these
books are by God it said that they were
originally sent by God and then and then
later on in the Quran it says and then
people have differed on their books and
uh and yes so context it's like the
Quran is saying that and also not just
in that one in that one verse is
decisive Authority use like decisive
it's never used it's never used as like
saying that the Quran is a decid of
authority in the in the of the previous
books there's no place in the Quran that
says that about the Quan is is the word
just always uh what's that Arabic word
the word actually is uh believe it's m
is that you said so that's the only
that's the only time MIM is used for for
for the previous books so when when I
say that the Quran uses the term
decisive Authority many times are you
saying that you have looked into every
single verse that says that the Quran is
a decisive Authority and you've looked
at the Arabic and you've done all this
so basically yes in regards to the
previous scriptures I've looked at I've
I've looked at this topic of what does
the Quran say about the previous
scriptures and its relation to them I've
studied that subject to a te I if I if I
like exit the Tik Tok app does it take
me off the live it won't take you off
the live uh yet like you you'll have
some time but you you can't stay off too
long like how long do I have probably I
don't know maybe maybe a minute and a
half or something like that or two but I
know that you can hear me as you're as
you're searching this stuff up yeah yeah
I can hear you so when the so that
you're absolutely right that the Quran
says that people defer about the book
right that people defer about the book
but but moderators can y'all stop life
oh shoot we we'll go back down oh man
hey everybody all the Muslims that are
that have requested that have been
coming up I'm dropping you but but
request again I'll bring you guys up
eventually what a what a loser the Bible
says not to repay evil for evil man
anyway so yes the people defer about the
book right they misinterpret what's
being said they argue about the meanings
but that does not mean that the meanings
or that the book itself is wrong or
corrupted just because people defer
about it like for example people defer
about the Quran people defer about the
Quran let's say like she she has and and
and uh sunnis no we don't on the Quran
yes you do you
guys no I'm Shia I'm a Shia that's why
I'm saying that or I was born as Shia
but I'm not I don't uh identify as that
anymore but we read the same Quran okay
so just like the Jews and the Christians
believe in the same Bible yes they defer
on meanings or interpretations in the
Bible right so so the Jews accept the
the New Testament they don't they don't
but there's no part of the Quran that
both Jews and Christians accept the Old
Testament they accept the Old Testament
however they disagree on some meanings
of the Old Testament right okay so you
have you know Muslims sunnis ahia
Muslims Shia you know ismali Muslims you
know stuff like that you got these
different Muslims that disagree on
interpretations of the Quran okay okay
doesn't that I'm sure you wouldn't say
that that makes the the of the Quran
corrupted in any way just because have
differ about the book different yeah
sure they have different uh
interpretations but I don't see it as I
don't think it's a good argument to say
that it's the same with Jews and
Christians because Jews completely
reject the New Testament it's like a
completely different thing like there's
no they don't they don't they don't say
that the New Testament is corrupted
though yeah but dude yeah because they
don't think it's anything worth even
looking at like they don't even look at
it as from God they look they thought
Jesus was a was a false man I mean like
there's no sect of Islam where they
notice notice the history where this is
coming from though the history where
this is coming from is in the seventh
century by the seventh century the old
and the New Testament were put together
oh now you have the Jews that reject the
New Testament but they still have the
Old Testament so when it says that the
Jews and the Christians are differing
about the book what part of the book are
they differing about the Jews and the
Christians uh differ on the book is that
you said yeah when it says that they the
Jews and Christians differ about the on
the book what part of the book are they
differing about I think that means that
they they differ on their own books
because the argument that we Muslims use
it's not just against Christians but
also against Jews like I also think the
Old Testament was or the Torah was not
properly uh transmitted or properly this
but this isn't the argument with the
Jews and the Christians the Jews and the
Christians their argument is who's the
messiah the Christians are saying the
Old Testament points to Jesus the Jews
are are reting Jesus as the Messiah of
the Old Testament right so no nobody is
saying that either book is corrupted or
distorted they're deferring on
interpretations okay yes so the book is
not corrupted just because they have
different understandings of what the
book is saying and which is what the
Quran says all the time it says that
they you know are you know changing
changing its meanings like they're
distorting the meanings in the context
that's chapter 5 verse 5: 13 where
they're changing the they hear the words
they says they hear the words but then
they change the words from the right
places after hearing it and knowing it
yes so they hear the message and then
change what the change what it says with
their mouths they're they're distorting
the meaning of it okay they're not going
into the actual book They're not going
into the T or the the New Testament and
changing actual words from the text yes
but but you're just looking at the Old
Testament though I mean you're you're
ignoring the fact that Jews completely
wholeheartedly reject the New Testament
they reject Jesus like it's a completely
different AR you're saying they you're
saying they reject the Quran too I don't
care yeah yeah yeah but I'm to use that
as an argument against different sectors
of Islam and how they might have
different interpretations and saying
that's the same as how Jews uh interpret
the New Testament it's different because
they don't interpret it at all they
completely reject that's not what I'm
saying I'm saying that people deferring
about the book does not mean that the
book is corrupted okay yeah okay so okay
so is uh is are you saying that the
Quran doesn't uh or substantiates that
uh that the Bible is not corrupted
correct the Quran substantiates the
reliability and authority of the Bible
okay so I think when we reach this point
I think it's hard to stay within
scripture and then we have to look at
theology like you're saying um like for
example it's you're saying the Quran
affirms the Bible and the Bible says
Jesus Is God right or or not the or not
even that the Bible says that because I
don't even think the because I can read
certain verses and interpret it in a way
that doesn't mean that Jesus is God you
know what I mean that's fine how how
about this how about we stick with
something that's more uh that's more
clear for you the Bible the the the
Bible is clear that Jesus was crucified
right the Bible wait repeat that the
right yes and the Quran rejects that yes
so let's go with that so Bible says
Jesus was crucified Quran rejects that
so take that example and and go with
what you were about to say wellit I'm
sorry repeat that the Quran affirms that
the Bible is true while at the same time
rejecting that Jesus was crucified so
what was the point that you're going to
make I was going to say um what's it
called are you are you going to say that
this shows that the Quran doesn't affirm
the Bible since it disagrees with what's
in it wait hold up I'm looking up
something are you guys enjoying this
conversation by the way I am in the
comments section you guys enjoying the
dialogue here between me and one who
submits I feel like it's a good
conversation I I like it favorite topic
Travis we got over a thousand people
listening to us go back and forth one
who submits one who submits bringing in
the views all my chef gear is at the
house y'all I'm not even I'm not even at
home man I'm I'm am out of state at the
moment visiting family and friends loved
ones and dear ones you feel me you ain't
got to get the URL okay hello yeah yeah
I'm back sorry I was uh what's it called
I was uh I was looking at like Hadith
just now okay wait um okay so your
question was um um repeat your question
so my my question because you it sound
like he was about to make a point um
about how the Quran says the Bible is
true but there are Parts in the Bible
that it disagrees with yeah to put it
simply yeah sure so this so from my this
this would be my argument against the
Quran okay my argument against the Quran
is that this shows how inconsistent it
is because it says that a book is true
right that it at the same time
contradicts so if the book is the if the
book is true that it contradicts then
that would mean that the Quran is false
because it's contradicting a true book
well I mean that goes back to like my
point before how the Quran uh because um
you know how I was saying that the Quran
calls itself a decisive Authority yeah
it's not it's not just that but there
are other places where just that that's
not if that doesn't exist you got there
are other verses where the Quran says
judge between them by what God has
revealed you know what I Jud between who
like between the books like like we said
we
it's not judged between the books it's
judged between them the People by what
Allah has revealed to you and follow not
their vain desires that's what the verse
says know I'm not I'm not talking about
that specific verse I'm saying there are
other parts that is you're literally
quing it that's the verse you're quoting
bro no I'm saying there are other parts
where that sentence is also used it's
say nowhere nowhere nowhere
does where the Quran says that the Quran
is is is how you interpret truth from
falsehood that is what the Quran is
saying let me let me let me just say
this one last time yes there is not a
single verse in the Quran nowhere in the
Quran where it says that the Quran is
used to judge what is true and what is
false in the previous scriptures there's
not a single verse that says that or
even alludes to it but what you do have
is the opposite you have the illusion
that it's the previous scriptures that's
used to judge what's right and what's
wrong in the Quran for example you have
chapter 10 chapter 10 verse
90 brain freeze brain fart shoot guys
help me out but I'm going just quote the
verse chapter 10 verse 90 something 92
for something where the Quran says this
talk unto Muhammad Allah says if you are
in doubt 98 thank you 1090 1094 1094
thank you Travis
1094 if you are in doubt Muhammad about
what we have revealed to you talking
about the Quran if you are in doubt
about what we have revealed to you go
and ask those who have been reading the
scriptures before you be not of those
who doubt surely the the your um your
lord has come to you in truth so if
Muhammad has doubts about the Quran
where where does Allah tell him to go to
verify that the Quran is true and that
his Revelations that he's getting are
true where does Allah say he needs to go
if he has doubts verse is it 1094 1094
you didn't hear me quote it no I heard
you quote it but I want to look at it
myself all right if you are in doubt
Muhammad go and ask the people who have
been reading the scripture before you
surely the truth has come to you from
your lord so this so this is about like
the when I'm reading it it's the
interpretation is of like the stories
you know what I mean that the stories
where the stories like the like no and
the arc and all that stuff let's be
specific okay so where do where is he
supposed to go to verify that what he's
getting is actually correct yes I I I
get what you're saying I agree to the
Christians sure exactly so you see how
the Quran uses the previous scriptures
as a decisive authority over the Quran
you see that no not not as a decisive
Authority no but I see what but I I get
what you're saying I don't think that
dismantles my point because I also
affirm that or I also agree that the the
Bible has like some truth in it or that
um like I I agree with that but it's
it's not just that the Bible has some
truth in it it's that the Bible is an
authority over the Quran when it it's
not an authority over the Quran it's if
he's in doubt about these stories or if
you if like as as in like oh like if you
don't believe them or if you feel like
you know you're in doubt about what we
have revealed to you that's what it says
if you are in doubt about what we have
revealed to you now let's say it's
regarding specifically the stories that
been let's talk let's say let's no no
worries what is he supposed to do in
order to check what Authority is he
supposed to use to verify that his
Revelation his Quran is actually correct
what's the authority it says yes then
ask those who read the scripture before
you like I don't see it as like go and
see if uh like go and check if like the
Bible is like the word of God and then
all this stuff it just says like it's
already it's already assuming that the
Bible is the word of God and it's it's
saying Muhammad if you're doubting the
Quran go check the Bible no I mean I
think we're just going in a circle
because like I said like the Quran what
it's talking about it's not talking
about the Bible it's talking about what
is affirmed and by God was what was
originally sent where where where what
do you mean where what what what book
did the did the Jews and the Christians
have for Muhammad to go to to verify his
Revelations what what did they have it
says ask those who read the scripture
before you ask them not read their book
okay oh my goodness what Authority would
they be using to say yeah Muhammad
actually what you're getting is correct
what what are they using yes the Bible
that would be at their time thank you so
it's already assuming that the Bible is
the word of God and it's authoritative
and preserve it doesn't say that the
Bible is the word of God here so then
why would Allah be telling Muhammad hey
man if you're in doubt about this
Revelation that I'm giving
you re wait wait let's let's actually
put what you're saying into actual
practicality hey Muhammad Allah Allah
speaking God hey Muhammad if you're in
doubt about what I've revealed to you
regarding these stories and these
Revelations about the prophets go ask
the people who are reading a
non-inpatient
go check and read a non inspired
non-authoritative book to check not
inspired not that it's not it was
originally inspired and these stories
are true like the the Quran affirms that
I have no problem with what you're
saying yes you do no I don't I don't
have any problem with what you're saying
right now okay so then what I'm saying
is is that the Quran says that the Bible
is authoritative the Bible okay here's
the thing if it's saying if if the Quran
is saying that the Bible has some of
these stories and that those stories are
true then we affirm that if the it
doesn't say stories it says Revelation
but it's the interpretation is with the
stories because this is after God are
those stories are those stories
Revelation because the verses previous
to that talk about God are those stories
Revelation no they what do you mean are
are the stories Revelation they they
have the verse says if you are in doubt
about what we have revealed to you so
Muhammad is doubting or may be doubting
at the verses previous to that look at
the verses previous to that so the
verses previous to that is talking about
Revelation correct no the vers previous
to that it says we brought 10 you're
talking about 10 this is crazy to me man
like like this is this is wild this is
this is4 and then look at verse 1090 we
brought the children of Israel is it
talking about Revelation or not no it's
not it's talking about story okay so
when Allah says okay guys we got it this
is how unclear the Quran is when Allah
says in the Quran chapter 10:94 if
you're in doubt about what we revealed
to you it's not talking about what's
revealed what is what is he revealing
what is he revealing oh who knows it's
not Revelation it's revealing he's
revealing the stories he's revealing
wait so are these stories Revelation
what are these stories Revelation the
stories they they happened they they
happen are they
Revelation what do you dude that
question is so like like are the stories
Revelation I mean to to Muhammad yes
it's Revelation okay beautiful their
Revelation so all says if you're in
doubt about the Revelation that we have
given to you what is he supposed to do
listen what is he supposed to do to
check these if this Revelation he's
getting corre the stories the revelation
of the stories it doesn't say does it
say of the stories dude when you read
the context in the context do say of the
stories in that verse no but you go stop
stop you you can't just stop up the
Quran stop it up stop adding I'm not
adding giving it to the Quran says
and over this whole time when the Quran
says that when Muhammad has doubts about
the Revelation he's getting where is he
supposed to go to check that his
Revelations are correct dude you're
ignoring the context in order to like
prove your point like there's no way for
me to answer it by by being truthful to
what the Quran is actually saying the
Quran when you go and you read the
verses leading up to that verse it
literally and that ladies and gentlemen
is the limit eventually there is a level
of dishonesty and I know you're still
here listening uh one who submits there
is a level of dishonesty that I have a
limit to that I have a limitation to
allow